una carpa instalada en la calle y
pupitres sobre una camioneta como aula
de aprendizaje está tortillería de
ciudad de méxico decidió prestar sus
espacios y dar acceso gratuito a
internet y a la televisión a los niños
del vecindario sin recursos tecnológicos
ni equipos en sus hogares para seguir
las clases en línea aquí en la
tortillería sabemos todo y empezamos a
platicar y poco a poco a ver oye tú cómo
vas a pasar este regreso a clases no
pues yo ni siquiera tengo esto o esto
esto no entonces entre los vecinos nos
fuimos organizando para poder apoyar
dávila siguió horneando tortillas pero
en la parte de atrás de la tienda entre
la harina de maíz también hay libros de
texto y material escolar un espacio que
sirve para unos 50 menores y varios
profesores voluntarios que les ayudan
con las materias
a mí porque antes
podía entender mucho entonces por la
tele ya no por el 24 de agosto se inició
una inusual vuelta a las aulas a través
de las pantallas debido a la pandemia
méxico es el segundo país con más
decesos por kobe 19 en américa latina'
si bien el 94 por ciento de los hogares
mexicanos cuentan con un televisor sólo
el 44 por ciento tienen una computadora
con la que los pupilos deben mandar sus
tareas a los docentes por eso así es muy
diferente en esta ocasión porque no hay
esa retroalimentación siempre las
ocurrencias que ellos tienen las
contestaciones en la alegría que te da
saber que lograron ellos construir el
concepto en esta ocasión pues no la
tengo el programa de naciones unidas
para el desarrollo prevé que 14 millones
de estudiantes de secundaria y educación
superior no regresarán a las clases de
este curso escolar otro de los efectos
de la pandemia la brecha en el
aprendizaje de los más jóvenes